une croix par victime 17 hommage à des
vies interrompues trop rapidement très
violent c'est comme un cimetière l'an ce
père de famille un endroit où l'on peut
laisser les émotions remonter à la
surface du prochain celui ci se sent
déprimé sans voix devant ces
disparitions
cette femme parle de besoin d'amour pour
tempérer tout la colère tout est bon
pour apaiser la souffrance
cela fait deux jours que cette
floridienne retraités guide son chien
col vert des jeunes bien éprouvé juan
somavia
sa mission est bien simple apporter un
peu de sourire même à un seul d'entre
eux des scènes auxquelles nous ne
pouvons pas assister
elles nous montrent ces images l'effet
de son golden retriever est bien visible
il y a aussi ce besoin d'agir de
réclamer haut et fort un accès moins
facile pour les armes à feu un appel
lancé dans les instants qui ont suivi la
fusillade
il faut que ça cesse exigeait cette
élève alors que les policiers
fouillaient encore son école à la
recherche du terrain celui-ci rêvait de
devenir acteur après la tuerie il parle
d'utiliser savoir autrement
il se veut un message est celui qui
tente de canaliser la colère des
américains pour faire pression sur les
élus ils ne parlent pas d'interdire les
armes mais il veut pays plus sûr
en attendant park lane pleure ses morts
d'ailleurs les premières des 17
funérailles ont eu lieu aujourd'hui le
début d'un deuil qui pourrait être long
ici il y avait du monde aaron
radio-canada park lane